even though Hollywood had a lot of
success in the 2010s the decade also had
plenty of cinematic train wrecks from
superhero slip-ups to animated
atrocities these are the biggest
box-office bombs of the last decade
directed by Karl wrench 47 Ronin arrived
with an impressive pedigree this Keanu
Reeves action movie wasn't just an
adaptation of a real-world historical
event in which 47 masterless samurai
avenged the death of their master
instead it was merely one of many
adaptations of that very same event
often referred to as the aku incident so
47 Ronin didn't just have a cool plot it
had centuries of proven success as
everything from lavish stage productions
to simple puppet shows basically 47
Ronin has a time-tested story that you
can bank on and yet it tanked the movie
missed every target that mattered
opening ninth in the US and delivering
dismal numbers in Japan there are many
reasons as to why with the most obvious
being the decision to insert fantasy
elements into the tale in retrospect
this is the most baffling choice did a
story already beloved for being about
awesomely talented warriors out for
blood really need a CGI Fox lady and
bird-like monks Hollywood thought so and
suffered for it 47 Ronin ended up losing
Universal an estimated 175 million
dollars some critics blame the script
while others thought the acting was a
bit wooden I have come for your help
we are in need of swords then take it in
the end it just goes to show that there
are no sure things when it comes to
movies especially when you try to cram
dragons into a classic story of 18th
century heroism Roald Dahl has generally
provided Hollywood with winning source
material Charlie and the Chocolate
Factory has been the basis for two
popular films James and the Giant Peach
is a stop-motion delight and Matilda is
a touchstone for 90s kids everywhere yet
somehow the film version of The BFG as
beloved as any of dollz other stories
flopped like a giant being dumped in the
ocean
having Steven Spielberg at the helm
didn't save it and generally positive
reviews didn't help it was a box-office
bomb in spite of it all leaving a trail
of questions in its wake why weren't
audiences raised on similar doll
adaptations eating this one up how did a
spectacle of this nature managed to
bring in only 18 point 7 million dollars
over its opening weekend how did its
final gross of a hundred and eighty
three point three million dollars only
barely clear its budget of one hundred
and forty million dollars the only
question this film really answers is
what would happen if Queen Elizabeth and
her dogs drank like a giant
one can't help but wonder if Spielberg
has simply lost this touch when it comes
to children's movies oh is the
Adventures of Tintin made an impressive
amount of money and received largely
positive reviews it hasn't entered the
Canon of the best Spielberg movies in
any substantive way it was fun but not
monumental seen in contrast The BFG
feels like a further slide down that
hill The BFG is a fine film but it's not
an event and audiences chose to spend
their money elsewhere now well at least
there's always Matilda ah to be a boy
discovering the joys of his first car
it's a classic American story about
creative drive and personal freedoms
similarly beloved are stories about boys
and their dogs they become best friends
across the lines of species forging and
understanding all their own you know
what else people enjoy weird monsters
especially when it comes to movies so
was monster trucks really such a bad
idea they combined all three of these
tropes into a movie about a boy and a
creature who uses the shell of a pickup
truck as a makeshift exoskeleton
theoretically no but practically yes
monster trucks had a long strange trip
to the theatre beginning as the first
film of a franchise that ended up
evaporating then having its release date
shifted multiple times by the time it
premiered paramount was already
expecting to lose money and it did
reviews were unkind and the worldwide
gross only cracked sixty four point five
million dollars monster trucks for all
its seemingly safe bats finished behind
the horror trainwreck the bye-bye man
and its opening weekend ticket buyers
might love stories about aliens cars and
dogs but as Hollywood should know by now
they might not love them all in one
movie take a moment to really let the
concept of a movie entitled Cowboys and
Aliens sink in it's a film title that
absolutely rules and it comes with a
good degree of flexibility beyond the
knows nature of it allows for a sense of
fun that doesn't threaten the spectacle
of well cowboys and Aliens add in Daniel
Craig and Harrison Ford and you've got
yourself a blockbuster yet none of that
mattered Cowboys and Aliens was a
genuine bomb from its lackluster opening
day what went wrong
reviews weren't terrible but their
meddling nature reveals the film's fatal
flaw a movie called cowboys & Aliens
really can't afford to play it safe
though some reviewers felt the film's
insistence upon playing it's absurd
premise straight was a strength more
found it to be a choice that hamstrung
production from the get-go ultimately
there are better cowboy movies better
alien invasion movies better Daniel
Craig movies and better Harrison Ford
movies the fact that the film barely
cleared its 163 million dollar budget
with a worldwide total of one hundred
and seventy four point eight million
dollars isn't much of a surprise nor the
fact that the movie fizzled out long
before anyone seriously considered the
possibility of a sequel I don't want to
do that again
superheroes are omnipresent and Marvel
is the goose that laid the golden eggs
for the most part consider the Fantastic
Four a longtime cornerstone in the
Marvel Comics universe their movies
historically having to mount it too much
with the 2005 film being the high-water
mark is a good enough jaunt that brought
in good enough money but the team was
owned by 20th Century Fox until recently
then it was consigned to a 2015 reboot
meant to compete with the dominant MCU
sadly for the Fantastic Four this
competition ended in failure and
reviewers had plenty of things to say
about the film however there is one
thing that absolutely no one said it's
fantastic why all the criticism it was a
terrible movie as dour as it was
overcomplicated Fantastic Four felt like
the sort of adaptation a 14-year old
might make after being mocked for liking
comic books
add in lopsided pacing and a convoluted
plots and you end up with the lowest
grossing Fantastic Four film of all time
a movie that lost the studio an
estimated 100 million bucks but now that
some time has passed will the MCU revive
the Fantastic Four we can only hope as
far as the 2015 reboot goes fans critics
and probably some of the cast wants to
forget that it ever happened Orson Scott
Card's 1985 novel Ender's Game has been
a classic for decades how many thousands
of people found their footing in the
world of science fiction through
enderwiggin story how many recalled a
shocking ending as one of the greatest
literary twists of their lives
the numbers are untold but the impact is
clear a movie based on Ender's Game was
primed for success
somehow however 2013's Ender's Game was
a dud despite the wealth of marketing
tie-ins a script for a sequel ready to
go and some pretty solid reviews the
movie grossed a mere 125 million dollars
only barely clearing its 110 million
dollar budget the reason for these
numbers are less obvious than other
similar Baum's
Ender's Game was solidly entertaining
visually engaging based on a celebrated
book and released for a public that
couldn't get enough of teen dystopias it
seemed that the movie was simply less
than the sum of its parts a bit too late
to the young adult franchise fad maybe a
bit too old in its source material to
intrigue today's audiences and likely
biting off a bit more than it could
choose story-wise what's certain is that
it failed that studio execs probably
wish they could go back in time and ask
themselves one very important question
what are you can redo waste millions on
a loser
clearly there won't be any sequels and
it looks like fans will have to content
themselves with Ender's adventures on
the written page which is still pretty
awesome for a species honed by years of
evolution to survive against all odds
humans sure do love seeing themselves in
mortal peril consider disaster movies
they're explicitly centered around
watching people die at the hands of
forces too huge and unknowable to ever
control and the genre is one of our most
beloved some come as a result of man's
overreach like Titanic while others like
twister are merely the wrath of the
winds themselves geo storm combined
these approaches by imagining a global
Cataclysm created by malfunctioning
satellites at humanity in their
arrogance installed to control the
weather
Tokyo is battered by a monster hailstorm
pockets of Afghanistan freeze over and
on and on it goes taking the audience on
a tour of worldwide destruction critics
ripped it apart to end with good reason
Geo storm is remarkably boring for a
movie of such epic proportions lacking
the jaw-dropping visuals that are the
entire point of the genre and the film's
humans are nothing to write home about
either though many
critically derided movies have gone on
to make money geo storm didn't even come
close to Warner Brothers expectations
yeah I think we've established that
Pixar is as close to a watchword for
quality as the movie industry gets
almost all of their films are commercial
and critical successes and many are
considered modern classics they were
featuring superheroes before Marvel
brought spandex back into vogue making
monsters lovable years ahead of Monster
High and introducing kids to
sophisticated French cuisine before
filed they're still ahead of the pack on
that one but no Enterprise is immune to
the occasional mistake enter the good
dinosaur Pixar's tale of an Apatosaurus
and his boy in an alternate earth where
dinosaurs never went extinct it's got
all the conceptual charm of a Pixar
knockout from an unlikely friendship to
an early heartbreak that must be
surpassed but something was missing the
reviews weren't bad but they weren't
quite up to Pixar's usual standard and
the box office followed suit the film
only made three hundred thirty two point
two million dollars remarkably short -
the film's three hundred and fifty
million dollar marketing and production
budget which by any standard is an epic
failure perhaps part of its lackluster
ticket sales can be chalked up to inside
out being released a few months prior or
the extensive revisions the film
underwent on its way to release or maybe
just maybe nobody wanted to see a film
that co-starred a grunting cave toddler
Justice League debuted at an odd moment
for DC the studio struggles to present a
decent film had not yet been eclipsed by
the successes of Shazam and Joaquin
Phoenix's Joker only Wonder Woman had
managed to impress critics with so much
competition for Marvel Justice League
had to be a mission statement and a
course correction all the while
introducing the flash cyborg and Aquaman
the fact that it disappointed isn't
surprising in light of this but it
doesn't mean it stung any less in
retrospect Justice League never had much
hope of recouping even its 300 million
dollar production budget it's one of the
most expensive movies ever made and it
needed to bring in at least 750 million
dollars to break even with all
associated costs but not even that
benchmark to be clear its worldwide
gross landed at 657 million dollars
reviews for the film were pretty
lukewarm which was better than what dawn
of Justice got but still not enough to
send the
world to the cinema in droves weighted
down with expectations Justice League
chugged forward as best it could but in
Hollywood once best isn't always good
enough even when it featured Batman
striking cool poses still Justice League
didn't disappoint everyone we're sure it
was loved by plenty of hardcore fans not
enough check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]